hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the speed chess championship
and chess.com
uh we checked out the game yesterday uh
from the five plus one section for those
of you who are new to this
uh it's a competition uh with three time
forms first they play
five minutes plus one second increment
then three minutes plus one second
increment
and lastly one minute plus one second
increment the so-called bullet
everyone's favorite
and this is one such game from the
bullet section uh
in the uh in the blitz section five plus
one hikaru ended it by uh leading with a
one point margin
then in a three plus one uh section uh
it was a draw so no one uh took the lead
there
and now everything has to be settled in
the bullet section and you do not wanna
be down a point
and facing uh hikaru in the bullet uh
but uh
like i said let's see what happened here
as the as the title suggests it's quite
the game
so maxine with the white pieces opens
with e4
sorry about that uh we have e5 by hikaru
uh and now knight to c3 the vienna game
we have knight to c6 and now f4 so sort
of like the king's gambit but considered
a bit more correct uh we have e captures
on f4 and
knight to f3 and here g5 much like you
would see in a king's gambit so
uh what do you do here uh well you could
play something like h3 to prevent the g4
but this is uh
actually what maksim wants hikaru to do
he goes bishop to c4
and hikaru says no problem g4 and here
maxine just castles and what do we have
here
g captures on f3 so that's the first
piece queen captures on f3
would could be played here uh but rather
uh maxine goes for
for a different move before recapturing
he goes bishop captures on f7
and now this is a completely crazy
position king captures
queen captures on f3 uh and now comes
queen to h4 and this is a he
this is hikaru's improvement on this
position because interestingly as
uh you'll see in the i i will put a link
in the description below to
uh an article by peter dodgers about
this whole event
uh so you can check out what happened in
in a lot of other games but
basically the two of them already had
this position on the board four years
ago
uh also on chess.com and the the game
ended uh very quickly he car played
bishop to h6
and then we have d4 and hikaru captured
it and now it's completely lost for
black uh here maxine just played queen
h5 check
king g7 and now bishop captures an f4
check preparing bishop to e5 which
pretty much ends the game
so here he tried to stop it but maxine
played it uh you know just the same and
it was in this position that hikaru
resigned because it doesn't matter what
you do for example if you capture
rook to f7 is just checkmate so uh by
repeating this i guess maxine was hoping
that he could get another quick win
in the bullet section however hikaru
improved with queen to h4
it is one of the engine's favorite moves
so uh it seems that hikaru remembers
that game very well and he checked what
to do
in such a such a position so
d4 by maxine and knight captures on d4
so again
the queen is under attack but now it's
not a problem to capture on d4 because
you don't have access to the h5 square
so queen back to d3 and now knight to e6
and the f4 pawn is protected twice so
hikaru is very safe here
but maksim grabs that pawn as well
bishop captures on f4
with knight captures by hikaru and now
knight to d5
with a double attack on the night of
course the queen cannot be captured as
the knight is pinned
but here comes the bishop to d6 adding
another defender here
and now comes knight captures on f4 uh
and here it's a very interesting
position hikaru
should go king to e8 and then he's just
uh he he just has a beautiful position
because the knight cannot move otherwise
you just get bishop captures an h2 and
it will lead the checkmate
so instead uh instead of king to e8
which is the
the absolute best move hikaru captured
but now he kind of allows
maxim to get back into the game here
maxine played the g3
again you cannot move the bishop and you
have to react your queen is under attack
so queen g5
and rook captures an f4 with king to e7
and now queen to d4
with an attack on the rook on h8 so
knight to f6
only good move for black and then now
comes rook to f5 chasing the black queen
away
from the defense of the knight here and
while you could do this then
maxine brings the other rook into the
game and it's a very very difficult
position to play
for black so instead maxime uh hikaru
said
uh all right we're just gonna play uh
something that makes more sense we're
gonna give up the queen so queen
captures on f5
and now again uh we have a game uh even
though uh black does have material to
counter
not having a queen uh his all of his
pieces are still undeveloped
so here e captures on f5 and now d5
uh the the pawn is nicely protected by
the knight the bishop can come into the
game
and hopefully hikaru will be able to
develop his pieces so queen e5
checked by maxine king to f7 and now
rook to e1
uh preparing to uh harass the king and
then pick up the knight so
rook to e8 only good move for black the
knight nicely defends the rook
and now queen captures on c7 and here
just bishop to d7
again nicely defending the knight covers
everything here so it's not a problem
uh and here we have rook captures on e8
you cannot go phone grabbing as the rook
on e1 is hanging so here
uh maxime trades once we have captures
captures and only now queen captures on
b7 and
it's a very very tricky position to play
black should be better as he does have
two pieces
and the rug but uh with so little time
on the clock and with the king not
having any defenses
at all it will be very hard to escape
all the checks from the white queen
so here rook to e2 a nice move as it
goes after the at the pawns here and
once you get to the light square bishop
into the game it will be
very very difficult for the white king
to escape
all the checks so queen captures on a7
rook captures on c2 and
now queen to d4 defending the b-2 pawn
now maxime has a nice past a pawn and he
wants to just push it to victory
so bishop captures on f5 by hikaru he
wants to cement this bishop on e4 and
then it's just going to be very hard for
white to play this
as as you'll see so a4 maxim starts
pushing his pass pawn and now bishop to
e4 and now all sorts of threats are
are possible here with h3 taking away
the g4 square from hikaru's knight
but just knight to h5 and here a very
complex position uh even uh
if you have a lot of time on the clock
and uh here
a move like queen a7 jerk followed by
queen b8 queen to b6 continuous
checking of the black king is what what
should go for
but here queen to e5 was played uh
attacking the knight here but now it's
just uh
well not possible for white to get out
of checks anymore rook the g2 with
check now the g3 pawn is covered and
the knight will easily grab that so if
you go king to h1 just knight captures
on g3 with
check and the white king has nowhere to
go you're going to have to give up the
queen
so of course maxine tried running away
to the queen side king f1 but now
knight captures on g3 with check one
rookie to check and now uh it was in
this position on move 30 that maksim
vashir lagrav
uh resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here
once you play king to d1 which is the
only move of course bishop to c2 check
is coming
you open a discovery towards the white
queen and it's just game over
uh king to c1 rook captures on e5 and
that's it
so really really amazing game a lot of
sacrifices
and even though hikaru uh knew the
absolute best response to the to the
position
he already lost the maxine four years
ago maxim still
was able to get a very playable position
out of this uh but
in the end he hikaru proved to be simply
too strong
and not only did he win the bullet
section but
out of the last eight games he car won
seven
and one one ended in a draw but that's
just incredible
so even though maxim could hold his own
in in five plus one and three plus one
when it comes to one plus one uh
hikaru simply reigns supreme
uh yeah so that's uh that's it for uh
this year's speech
championship hikaru is the overall
winner uh
we'll we'll see what happens uh in the
next one he he crushed everyone
and it was something also interesting in
the article hikaru said that his part of
the bracket was
much tougher than uh carlson's part of
the bracket but now that
maksim actually defeated carlson and he
got into the finals
then it would seem maxim had the tougher
bracket
than car to reach the final uh so yeah
uh once again i do hope you guys enjoyed
it do check out uh the link
in the description below that i
mentioned and also as a bonus i received
another uh voiceover of the age of
kaiser chapter 1
from a certain gentleman so if you guys
want to check that out as well
as well that's really enjoyable i will
put a link to that in the description
below as well
while we await chapter 2 of the age of
kaiser
uh so i would like to thank tishontong
david kimura pranav singh
sarang yoshi and richard wagner for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day
and i might show an uh a game or two
more from the speeches championship but
we'll see see you soon